welcome to this video playing wall turn
by turn from Argentina let's see Queens
gambit I've played the sky number of
times before five and five point five of
nine so at least I'm a positive score
but not overwhelming yeah the Vienna I
don't really have anything against that
yeah I had to try this I've tried this
this pawn sacrifice and found out to be
prompted to be quite interesting 95
Queen g4 this is not easy to play for
black and it has been played by some
strong players I think Aronian used it
to be done and once i'm not mistaken
yeah white has very nice piece play and
of course this the strong knight on d5
just Bishop to h6 I guess and now
probably rookie one just going for peace
play okay right maybe to have five yes
hmm i don't have anything directly I
won't ever should maybe get the Bishop
tutu to hear this is probably the better
place in the long run as h7 now is the
point that I want to attack probably now
that's ambitious
interesting maybe ok I start with this
not quite sure what the most precise
move what is
maybe maybe all the way back yeah I'm
always amazed at how quickly some
sometimes very those very complicated
positions are played this is so easy to
play yeah well okay okay let's do let's
do this at serve its many many
possibilities here
this is why why I went to see one so
that I have rookie 3h three okay so look
h3 on something else o gauge three is so
very normal maybe maybe do that if it
takes on e5 de there is really the
direct threat of Queen age 595 Bishop h7
that I thought I cannot believe in at
all
yeah here I maybe also maybe I'm also
threatening night f 7 am-9 f7 king of
seven rogue age 7 and it's that's
dangerous and quite clearly ok so so
night f7 on yeah Queen Queen h5 is also
quite dangerous but ok is covering the
a3 square at the moment yeah i wonder if
i should just recapture night f7 King f7
rook age 78 while loop while looking
dangerous he's covering the fifth-ranked
so maybe recapture for the moment
yeah my back ring is weak this is what
what we live really irritates me the
Queen you want checkmate you think the
fear can do something ok and now queen
age five how do you defend
this also rook h7 interesting King takes
Knight f7 threatening Queen g6 oh wow
this is really really dangerous I would
see I protect this I don't see if how
Bishop g6 is also interesting but this
it seems only leads to a draw Queen
takes to g8 time I don't see don't see a
win then I cannot use the rook but this
year this is interesting threatening
Queen g 6 and 9 h 6
okay what is the possible defense yeah
if I am Bishop e8 maybe maybe maybe this
is sam as a defense maybe Bishop II aid
covering f7 at the moment I don't see a
win against the screen g6 king here I
don't don't see a win at the moment
night age 6 p.m. and then
check check yeah running low on time
maybe this isn't winning it's possible
it's it looks very dangerous but it does
not seem to win he's always covering a
three year which is the problem Bishop a
three would be the killer but it's not
it's not them cannot move the night no
as there is Queen d1 check mate check
yeah I will lose one time it was just
far too much time spent i was really am
now this was made to meet him I must
meet him here yeah okay quite resigned
this is I didn't find the maid there was
one that's pretty clear so yeah queen
age 5 vs is totally winning okay yeah I
thought this was good as well but Bishop
e8 okay Bishop g6 is winning check and
this is not winning well maybe it is I
am check and spend too much time as
often I he I can just take the rook i
forgot i totally forgot about that that
i can just take the rope him check yeah
and three points of Johnny yeah it was
pretty clear should be a winner I mean
check like wasn't in dire straits one
term but I didn't fight didn't find to
find the killer queen h5 was the easiest
yeah well I just thought that I had seen
Bishop II age rather rather late it's so
let's see how this wins yeah this was
clear 95 check eggs takes it takes hmm
and no what is the this thing here ah ok
i see hmm now that's not easy not easy
here after Bishop b5 i had seen this but
i wasn't sure what what to do next here
and yeah this is very strong here
allowing Bishop e3 check and this is
this is winning know something that it's
just totally winning for white yeah this
that I didn't see
that I didn't see really very this is
very very complicated yeah okay my move
and it seems winds also yeah maybe I
should have settled for the draw but I
only now saw Bishop e8 that this is some
sort of a defense yeah it was it was
clear that I can can can do is just this
a draw with another time this was maybe
wise but I only now Sabah should be
eight so um the problem was that i
thought i would would win anyway in
check here the chat was also thinking
yeah but i didn't see anything against
that okay queenie six is strong yeah
computer chess fulfill a four is strong
very strong and if the Queen takes this
rook e1 and Queen g8 checkmate very nice
very nice you know this is why it's a
brutal against the computer it would
absolutely never spoil such a position
will always find those kind of great
attacking moves okay thanks for watching